[Music]
just as faith and pure insight belong in
common to the element of pure
consciousness so also are they in common
the return from the actual world of
culture consequently they present
themselves according to three aspects
first each is an intrinsic being on its
own account apart from all relationships
second each stands in relationship with
the actual world in an antithesis to
pure consciousness and third each is
related within pure consciousness to the
other
here in this very short paragraph number
530 Hegel is setting out for us a
tripartite movement or rather tripartite
mode of analysis that he's going to
carry out in the next several paragraphs
to come all of which are quite short
until we get to the end of this section
which which by itself is not
particularly long faith and pure insight
we started out with with two fairly long
paragraphs then we have this marathon in
529 and now Hegel is going to bring this
to kind of a close and begin again so he
says just as faith and pure insight
belong in common to the element of pure
consciousness we saw this in 429 they
are both connected to each other as
Hegel mentioned just a little bit
earlier faith is pure consciousness of
essence and therefore it is thought but
it has content but not self
consciousness whereas insight has self
consciousness but not content Hegel now
is interested interested in how do we in
fact bring these together and how do we
move from faith into the pure insight
that is going to lead us by the end of
this to the historical movement of the
Enlightenment so he says just as faith
and pure insight belong in common to the
element of pure consciousness soul also
are they in common the return from the
actual world of culture and here we have
a very important theme that's starting
to be elaborated so why did we arrive
here in the first place the actual world
of culture turned out to be kind of a
bust we saw first this struggle with you
know self-consciousness trying to figure
out where it fit in as Noble in relation
to state power and then wealth and the
its opposite the ignoble conscious
there's a lot of back and forth and back
and forth with that and we eventually
wound up with
culture is being this place of
alienation that that language made
possible and we saw that there was an
attempt on the part of some sort of you
know naive or or you know we might say
good thinking consciousness to
recuperate that and it just totally
failed so now we have this this jump
into the supersensible beyond which is
in consciousness pure consciousness and
it is is thought so Hegel says first
faith and pure insight are going to
present themselves under the aspect of
what's being translated here as
intrinsic being on its own account which
is really on infers e-zine being in and
for itself so what is it it's being as
such what is the being of faith what is
the being of pure insight apart from any
sort of relationship or connection to
anything else what are they in and for
themselves now to ask what they are for
themselves takes us beyond merely the in
itself because remember through zigs ein
has a certain reflexivity to it so
that's going to be quite important so
that's going to happen in the next
paragraph then Hegel is also going to
talk about the relationship of both of
these pure insight and faith to the
actual world what is this actual world
the actual world of culture the actual
world of alienation the actual world of
these spiritual powers of wealth state
power and and moving beyond them right
so he says each stands in relationship
with the actual world the actual world
is being placed in an antithesis with
pure consciousness but pure insight and
faith are in fact pure consciousness
then there's a third factor as well each
of them exists in a relation to the
other as its other so pure insight has
faith as its other faith has pure
insight as its other notice what they
don't have as their other the actual
world as a matter of fact you might say
that at this point in time both of them
have surpassed the actual world and
they're battling out amongst each other
in terms of which one is going to
dominate pure consciousness and the
answer of course is it's going to be
your insight but we have to see how we
get there so Hegel is going to bring
this to a close by saying each is
related with in pure consciousness to
the other to its other and notice that
we really have three different terms
here we have faith we have pure insight
and then we have the actual world and
what's going to happen in the paragraphs
to come is going to play off of each of
those
in the consciousness of the believer the
aspect of being in and for its off is
its absolute object whose content and
determination we already know for
according to the notion of faith it is
nothing else but the actual world raised
into the universality of pure
consciousness the articulation of this
world therefore constitutes the
organization of the world of faith
except that in the latter the parts do
not alienate themselves in their
spiritualization but are beings each
with an existence of its own spirits
which have returned into themselves and
abide with themselves the moment of
their transition into one another is
therefore only for us an alienation of
the specific character in which they
exist in their distinctiveness and is
only for us a necessary series for faith
however their difference is a tranquil
diversity and their movement a real
happening
here in paragraph 531 Hagel is now going
to explore that first aspect at least in
relation to faith that is it's Ian and
for its self being it's on and pers
design all right and he says in the
consciousness of the believer the person
who is engaged in believing the aspect
of being in and for itself is its
absolute object whose content and
determination we already know now why do
we in fact already know its content and
determination this is something worth
actually lingering over does Hagel mean
that as the phenomenologist looking over
history this is closer to us in time say
that the master-slave dialectic or some
of the other dialectics that we've seen
and so we're very familiar with this may
be because there are still vestiges of
it going on within our own we might say
life world or is it that we've already
seen this complex play itself out before
in an earlier stage or could it be both
that's something worth lingering over
and I'm not going to actually answer
that at this point so he's talking about
the believing consciousness and faith
itself is not just the person who is
believing or the person who has faith
who's exercising faith we might say his
faith belief both the same or globe and
right and it's related to a world it's
related to an object but that object is
a complex object it's taking in a whole
range of things now where is it getting
that from this is where Hegel is saying
something quite interesting let's see
what he says first and then we'll talk
about how we might interpret this so he
says according to the notion of faith
the Magritte right it is nothing but the
actual world raised into the
universality of pure conscious
us so we have this actual world and what
is the actual world not just an actual
world of objects but an actual world of
human culture which we have just seen is
full of all these you know
contradictions and ways in which you
know even the very perspective on that
culture is alienating and this is being
raised to a universal so does that mean
that we're universalizing discordance no
somehow in the world of faith we wind up
with something that's a harmony we wind
up with some sort of integration how is
it possible from a world of culture that
we're transcending that we're moving
beyond Hegel says that we raise this
actual world into the universality of
pure consciousness
remember pure consciousness he brings us
up over and over again pure
consciousness is the eye which has this
capacity of synthesizing of bringing
things together of integrating them in
some way or at least making it seem like
that's happening because usually in the
dialectic it never turns out that
anything is perfectly integrated so he
says that this articulation of this
world constitutes the organization of
the world of faith there's a vital
difference here though he says in the
world of faith the parts do not alienate
themselves in their spiritualization but
are beings each with an existence of
their own spirits which have returned
into themselves and abide with
themselves so there's something like a
community going on here and we'll
speculate about what he might have in
mind in just a moment but but let that
sink in here in the actual world of
culture there is discordance as we raise
it to universality we are drawing upon
the actual world but we're somehow
transforming what we're idealizing you
might say what we're abstracting into
things that
can hold our our attention and present
themselves as having more being than
even the actual world so he tells us the
movement of their transition into one
another the movement of the transition
of what was you know discordant beings
here into these spirits that are not
discordant with themselves or with each
other he says is therefore only for us
an alienation of the specific character
in which they exist in their
distinctiveness where do they exist in
their distinctiveness well really in
both of these worlds the world of the
actual culture in which we live in which
we have our individuality and the world
of faith which has been revealed as a
world of pure thought so he says it is
this movement is for us a necessary
series but for faith their difference is
a tranquil diversity and their movement
here's something really interesting a
real happening
agasshi in' things are actually
occurring now what might Hegel have in
mind here perhaps we might think in
terms of the you know Christian notion
of the community of the Saints
individuality x' who can be connected
together can all be on the same page in
what the medieval is call they you know
concordia right a Concord a harmony with
each other I don't know that we
necessarily need to think about this in
terms of Christianity we might think
about this in terms of other faiths
where there's something from the actual
world and it is transformed into you
might say a pantheon that actually works
now historically of course Hegel does
have in mind Christianity but he doesn't
have in mind the kind of Christianity I
suppose that he wants to leave behind
through the Reformation or does he could
this be
preliminary stage along the way so the
interpretation is not yet settled and we
need to look ahead to see where pure
insight now is going to get involved but
it's very important to notice this this
transition to a world not just an object
of faith but a world of faith
to name them briefly according to the
external determination of their form
just as in the world of culture state
power or the good whose primary so here
two the first is the absolute being
spirit that is in and for itself insofar
as it is the simple eternal substance
but in the actualization of its notion
in being spirit it passes over into
being for another its self-identity
becomes an actual self-sacrificing
absolute being it becomes a self but a
mortal perishable self consequently the
third moment is the return of this
alienate itself and of the humiliated
substance into their original simplicity
only in this way is substance
represented as spirit
now in paragraph 532 Hegel is continuing
his analysis of faith or globin he has
just made this important transition or
contrast between the actual world of
culture which is finding a correlate in
the world of faith the actual world of
culture of course there's kind of
disruption going on and contradiction
but over here we have this at least at
first what appears to be this you know
harmonious world of faith but now Hegel
is going to describe a transition that's
happening a dialectic within the world
of faith in terms of the the beings or
perhaps the being itself of these these
spirits and Hegel tells us at first that
this is similar to what was happening in
the dialectic of wealth and state power
and he doesn't fully spell this out but
we might want to remind ourselves so he
says we begin with the good or state
power and you remember that noble
consciousness had to figure out well
where does it fit in with this and
eventually that led us to the point
where we moved away from the good being
state power and we looked at wealth
which was this self-sacrificing thing
that that actually wasn't completely
sacrificing itself and it undid much of
what had been gained in in the process
about the noble consciousness and its
service to state power in now and of the
noble consciousness became dependent
upon the self giving wealth right
meaning the wealthy person so Hegel's is
saying something similar is happening
here in the world of faith between these
three moments the instances to name them
what what is them these spirits briefly
according to the external determination
of their form he says in the
actualization of its notion in being
spirit in the actualization of being
made actual of the const
in in in being spirit it's going to go
into a dynamism right he says the first
is absolute being spirit that is in and
for itself insofar as it is the simple
eternal substance so this is what the
consciousness of faith is at first
relating itself to and and it finds
there a kind of satisfaction all right I
found God I found the gods
I found spirit I found something that is
an eternal substance something I've been
looking for a place to put my my heart a
place to invest my desires with and it's
even better you know it's it's really
substance it's not just a figment of my
imagination it's something that's out
there that I can have faith in that
gives way however as Hegel says to an
actual self-sacrificing
being and I think what we want to see in
here is a reference to if not just
Christianity certainly something where
we have historical determinacy
identification of some individual as the
God or the divine or the locus where
these things are happening and this this
element of self sacrificing is
absolutely essential there it cannot be
a God who shows up and you know is just
a human being writ large and says AHA
worship Me I'm super powerful I will
give you whatever Noah there has to be
an element of sacrificing its own being
so he says it becomes a self by doing so
it's no longer merely a substance
substance is pretty good but substance
without self isn't quite so good is it
he says it becomes an it becomes a self
but a mortal perishable self a self that
we ourselves can in some sense identify
with
can learn from can see ourselves in then
in the Hegelian three step right okay he
says consequently the third moment is
the return of this alienated self and of
the humiliated substance so the first
two stages into their original
simplicity and he says only in this way
is substance represented as spirit so if
we were just focusing on the absolute
being on the eternal substance we're not
really grasping the eternal substance as
spirit then that's kind of a problem for
the Hegelian it has to pass through this
other stage where it becomes personified
and not just personified as an abstract
principle and something like you know
God on earth doing everything that God
would possibly do but a being that can
be self-sacrificing because it shows
itself as vulnerable this Hagel thinks
is what is going on within the world of
faith and this exploration of what this
spirit or spirits and the plural are
that the believing consciousness relates
itself to in its pure consciousness in
its mode of thinking
these distinct beings when brought back
to themselves by thought out of the flux
of the actual world are immutable
eternal spirits who's being lies in
thinking the unity which they constitute
removed thus from self consciousness
these beings are nevertheless actively
present in it for if the absolute being
were to remain unmoved in the form of
the first simple substance it would
remain alien to self consciousness but
the external ization of this substance
and then its spirit involves the moment
of actuality and thereby makes itself a
participant in the self consciousness of
the believer or the believing
consciousness belongs to the actual
world
paragraph 533 is very short and on its
own I think would almost be
unintelligible so what we want to do is
keep in mind what has just happened in
the previous several paragraphs when
he's talking about these distinct beings
when we just had in the previous
paragraph a distinct being we must now
think this plurality of multiple beings
we're talking again about the the world
of faith right where we have these
different spirits that are all related
to each other as Hegel says they are in
a kind of unity so he says these
distinct beings when brought back to
themselves by thought out of the flux of
the actual world that's referring to
what happened in just you know the
paragraphs before where the the world of
faith is really you might say a
projection or
a Transfiguration of the world of
culture that the the person exists
within and is trying to get past so he
says when they're brought out of this
this flux of the actual world they
become immutable eternal spirits and we
just saw discussion of this spirit as
substance and they says they're being
lies in thinking the unity which they
constitute so whether we're talking
about a pantheon or whether we're
talking about the Trinity or whatever we
conceive the divine as a community of
the enlightened something is going on
here where the believer who's not in
that community as such can relate
themselves to something that has come
out of the actual world of culture and
now exists in a kind of you might say
pure pristine harmonious State that's
not all there is to the story though so
Hegel is going to go on and he says
removed thus from self-consciousness
when those beings are are sublimated
like that they are being removed from
self-consciousness we can attribute a
thinking on their part but we don't
really know what it is
like for God to think you know it's
unity with itself or thought thinking
itself of Aristotle we were we have to
find ways to connect that back to us so
he says these beings are nevertheless
actively present in self-consciousness
why because they're an object for the
believing self-consciousness so he goes
on and he says if the absolute being
were to remain unmoved in the form of
the first simple substance it would
remain alien to self-consciousness
we need an advance here we need these
beings somehow to not be alien to self
consciousness so that self-consciousness
isn't just left on its own kind of
looking at the from a distance and
wondering how do I ever get there we've
already done that in the unhappy
consciousness right so he goes on and he
says the external ization of this
substance and that its spirit involves
the moment of actuality thereby makes
itself a participant in the
self-consciousness of the believer or
the believing consciousness belongs to
the actual world
why is Hegel making an identification
they're saying that these really amount
to the same thing the relation of these
becoming actual within the self
consciousness of the believer or the
believer being part or resuming their
part in the actual world well we might
think of this as a connection between
these right and this but it's actually a
reconnection with the actual world of
spirit with self consciousness being the
important juncture point between them
you